hate and darkness may seem like it's
winning at half time
but love and brightness and kindness
always always wins the game
when the clock strikes zero
i'm a purebred entrepreneur for real for
real for real like documented
[Music]
your favorite marvel character when i
got into comics for as a reader in like
seventh grade
i
loved fantastic four
the human torch
was my guy
thing i'm not a i'm not a big captain
america guy i'm not a big um i'm not as
big as spider-man guys most people you
know
i would go with human torch
so this is pretty crazy i'm literally
backstage
at
uh
at brand minds
in bucharest romania
all these years later five years later
and sure enough
with the recession looming
the big theme for the rest of this year
for everybody who's watching this is
really actually saving money so please
take a step back and realize all the
things that you want to accomplish
require
uh financial
smarts and with everything looming the
time to get smart
what's your name my name is eddie nice
to meet you
the idea is that i feel that i have
something bigger inside me that wants to
go out but in the same time i have
something that is keeping me at a
certain level maybe it's it's fear it's
overthinking it feels like the fear of
what others could say fear yeah that's
that's this at the end of the day the
thing i think that makes me not scared
is i know that all of them don't care
because their judgment shouldn't matter
to you because you have to realize it
doesn't matter to them
[Music]
over the last five years
us human beings have gotten very good at
something
let me tell you what that is
we in the last decade have become
remarkable
at blaming everyone and everything
besides our own selves it may not be fun
to face the mirror and understand your
shortcomings it's not fun for me i have
plenty
but i promise you
you want some anxiety to come off your
chest
you want to smile a little more than
worry
it starts with accountability and i
believe as we head into this
decentralized world accountability will
gain momentum and that
will be good for society
bucharest i love you thank you for
having me
i think it was a very compelling
like
clarity like i really liked it
what do you think clarity on just like i
think it helped people understand
i like when i like when i feel the
audience like learning gotcha you know
like oh right it's not just like
a turtle with a [ __ ] banana up its
ass
you know what i mean
this is real [ __ ] technology yeah
ready
yep
the
message that i would tell the entire
world if they were watching right now is
never be confused hate and darkness
may seem like it's winning at halftime
but love and brightness and kindness
always always wins the game
when the clock strikes zero
everything you think
that nobody else is thinking is actually
true
just trust yourself let me tell you what
i meant there because dustin asked me to
you believe things today that most of
the world doesn't i think it's better to
stick to it and see it all the way
through especially when it's positive
it's just sometimes it's really hard to
see like i would have never thought
like i always wanted to be a video
editor when i was 14. like but i just
was like oh i can't be that's not gonna
be a
and here's my point ready for this you
would be a better one
yeah because if you [ __ ] oh man i
wish there was a video on you your face
right now you'd be a better one because
if you believed it all the way you would
have you would have you would have
[ __ ] went all in i want to give
the 15 year olds of the world the 30
year old confidence
actually i've never said that before
that
is really what
that clip
that what am i up to
i'm advancing self-confidence
how are you hello hello nice to meet you
hello
thank you for having me cheers
yeah i'm really proud of you
let's take just an ordinary
family yes in milwaukee wisconsin i love
this i love the question around middle
class keep going middle class upper
middle class yes
how are they going to own and use nfts
what is the what is the their their
favorite coffee shop that sells them
seven dollar latte right the punch card
that gives them an 11th free coffee will
be an nft in a decade it's creating
infrastructure that people can't see yet
that's a beautiful example of the
mundane smb
normal person
that was so fun yeah that was so fun
listening thank you
that was enjoyable send me those uh
something like that 100
we're starting an nft project in romania
and good luck we own a coffee shop that
sells uh accepts cryptocurrency amazing
and when i
released press release we had only two
um two buyers yes that's it and everyone
laughs about us yes and i said [ __ ] you
i love when they laugh
when they laugh you know it's gonna be
good exactly good for you i'm proud of
you you're ahead of me
yet
yet you know how many orders i used to
get on winelibrary.com in 1995. one
two
one
two
patients
that's just like all time it's almost
like maybe you talk over it in the
podcast be like by the way five seconds
later gary took five steps and this
conversation happened go figure either
like that might be a good you see where
i'm going that'd be neat let's do that
promise me okay i'm gonna bring back my
old wine library tv
skill sets here we go thank you my
friend thank you all right on the snippy
stamp move back to australia two weeks
ago
and they won't let me go in germany and
they go well can you do homework in
australia
yeah i think if you're different
this is nice but it's
strong good news i i have russian chest
hair
i can drink this [ __ ] there you go i've
got the vodka dna cheers cheers to good
health
gary oh here we go yeah guys yeah he's
like
he's been there done that
eat this
that's my dad's favorite thing in the
world what is it
when i tell you
i ate this every day of my life from
like 7 to 15.
[Music]
i have to say that i admire
okay
[Music]
yes out of the 12 which are
two of the most important things that
you taught them from them of the twelve
and a half parts of course
you know i think when i think about the
book and like how i think about
the kids i think um
accountability the second we all decide
that somebody else's fault for our
unhappiness is the second we're unhappy
i want my children to be compassionate
and empathetic to other human beings
obviously they have a very different
life than i did and they're very blessed
and it requires them to be double
compassionate and empathetic and so
those are the two that stand out
thank you so much
[Music]
how can i keep my daughter
nine years old
away from these dangers from the
internet only two things
one
you actually don't let her spend time on
it
which as you know is very hard because
everybody in her world will be on it
two and this is the most important
the number one way to protect the child
is to build their self-esteem
when a child
is not insecure
they don't succumb to danger if you make
her confident in who she is that she's
amazing the way she is she will not
succumb to other people
and that is how she will navigate
very nice
thank you i'll sit right here
all right we'll get to know each other
we'll talk yeah i'm excited i'm excited
okay okay i wanna i intuit my intuition
says yes
now we spend the next two three weeks
and do it okay and then we take the next
step i really liked him i really like
the product and i'm gonna spend some
time to dig under the hood thank you
thank you
pleasure to meet you brother see you
guys always good to see you so we'll see
you in april bye hopefully before yeah
thank you you did a great job thank you
thank you thank you nice meeting you
nice meeting you
thank you namaste thank you
thank you bro
all right
thank you we're the fans yes we love you
we love you i love you guys